We have many days here at Film Courage where
we feel like giving up.
We imagine you’ve had days like this also.
[Filmmaker Kiowa Winana speaking] “You look
down both sides of the tunnel and you’re
right in the middle.
You have to make a decision.
Do we stop here and start walking backwards
or do we just keep going?”
[Actor Steve Tom speaking] “She’s just
been at it.
I remember the long conversation we had on
the telephone on why this business was terrible,
there is no opportunity for advancement for
her and nothing was working and she just felt
like she was on a hamster wheel
going nowhere.”
[Filmmaker Mike Hedge speaking] “Sometimes
it is best to just…
just..call it
and...
and do something else.”
[Actor John Nicholson speaking] “Whenever
I think about this
business is just t
too hard
or
I want
to quit
or maybe
I
should
give it up…”]
Maybe one of our videos helped you on one of those days?
Other than the views and comments this channel
receives, it’s hard to feel the real impact we are having.
In that spirit, we are launching this video
contest.
Tell us which one of our videos is your favorite
and the impact it has had on you.
Whoever submits the video we enjoy most will
win $100 US Dollars.
So whether you view it as an opportunity to
give back to us or whether you simply want a chance at $100 dollars…
We look forward
to hearing your stories. No entry fee is required.
Must be 18 years or older to enter.
Rules and guidelines are listed below.
Thank you for watching!